All right, we might or for everybody who's new, we've got a few new people on here that you can certainly go to our website and search questions between times if you're looking for an answer.
Also, please use the members only site for all our announcements.
These are our weekly announcements.
Everybody should check out our new courses.
Don't please don't go pay for any courses.
You can see that on our regular website. You'll see a tab says courses.
We have a course stop fighting cancer course, which nobody here needs because you have all that information on the web that are cited more.
There is a detoxification course that goes through my both the seven phases of detoxification that somebody your family might find interesting.
And if somebody in your family or somebody you know that has a live disease or a live course three phases of life is going live.
Actually, I think tonight.
So we'll have a course on the right that I finished.
Just to clean it up and of course on genetics that I finished just to clean that up.
And those will be live in the next couple of weeks.
But all of our patients, all of you are going to have free access to all those courses, not that you need more information in your head.
But you'll have access to all those courses.
So we have to just figure out how to be able to give you access.
So don't purchase those courses. It's a family member that they have to purchase it for the medium family.
We'll have free access to those courses.
I also added about 20 new videos on the right page, a bunch of small Q&A short videos.
Most of them are under a few minutes, but they're just Q&A on different things if you're an expert on right already.
So that's all of the ins and outs.
There's really for new people.
So make sure you remember to jump on Monday Zoom call if you want to do that too.
Before I get to the questions, somebody chatted and went in a few weeks ago, I noticed that my.
Number two eye on the flowway program doesn't make the bulb even flicker.
We try to look at it, which I have done a lot lately, because I just noticed this the light is solid blue.
Could this be a side of a problem?
Hopefully you mean the light on your eye and pro way, because if it isn't high and pro way program, hopefully are only ready to on the high and pro wave, not on the bulb.
But it should be yes on the high and pro. Okay. Yeah, that should be just fine.
You can keep using it. It doesn't always flicker. Right. Let's get to some of your questions.
Should all patients be taking vitamin D? If not recommended through the testing.
If so, how much and what brand?
Yes, probably not everybody needs to be taking vitamin D through the summer. If you get outside a lot.
The brand. There's multiple really good brands of vitamin D.
I like it's you should be using vitamin D three, but that's about all you can find now any.
I like a vitamin D that also has the other fats all you can write about is in it.
Because I do think there's a city just to connect with the fats all you have the supplements.
So we use that ADK avail.
That's the product of designs for health. Now I think we have a private label.
That's I think one of the better products of the market.
Partly because it has the full has the delta total treat on the e unit.
Where some of the full spectrum.
Vitamin D's mean full spectrum meeting that they're carry the other fats all over the vitamin.
Some of them are only carry the health to crop.
And you really want the total tree and all of the vitamin.
Are there any other supplements vitamin or center that you would recommend everyone to take?
Well, if you're doing the greens product, so if you're taking the greens first.
There is a necessary you need to be taking these other things because that is multiple in itself.
So no, some people have deficiencies in minerals for different reasons.
So like for me, in the summertime, I'm out gardening. That's what I love to do.
So my wife and I are really big gardeners. I wish I could have it all over the house to see all our areas beds and all our gardens.
This is just we just love to do that. So we're outside sweating a lot. So we take minerals every day.
Besides the greens first. So that's something we take.
I do not take vitamin D in the summer, unless I feel like I'm coming down with something or something.
Just feeling off that I'll take some vitamin D.
But I always take minerals in the summer.
This is because of that. If you're doing it sawdust and you know, a couple times a week, it might be good to have minerals as well because you're sweating.
The more you're sweating, you're sweating out toxins. That's the benefit of the sauna that's a benefit of going outside of the summertime and really sweating.
But you are those heat minerals too. So you just want to make sure you got dehydrated.
Just by drinking water. We have well water that has minerals in it, but still we take minerals because I can feel.
I could just tell my legs get kind of crampion stuff for no reason, probably deficient in some minerals.
After the black sav falls off the tumor.
It's sometimes this is a person that's doing black sav on a topical tumor.
It sometimes don't always is soft and mushy. I try to remove some of the debris and lose pieces before reapplying the black sav.
While the tumor is soft and it wouldn't take much to remove some pieces, I try not to irritate it too much as it pleads easily, but she's trying to remove some of the tumor.
The question is, how much de-broadment can I do at a doing so? Do I risk spreading cancer? You don't risk spreading cancer. You just don't want to rip off tissue that you may end up causing a bad bleed. That would be the only thing.
I would be careful using any instrumentation to remove it, but if you can pick away things, I don't think there's any problem with it.
I am low on energy. I have been doing the right energy program a couple times this past week during the nap and I've been wearing energy patches three times a week.
My appetite has been suppressed suppressed for a couple of weeks, except for a few days. I located the right appetite program and have now run in two consecutive days. How often can I run this daily?
Okay, let's stop right there. This person is investigating the programs on his right and I commend him for that. That's just great.
That's what I want you guys to do. So I wrote those programs for your cancer that you're running nightly programs and I have some day programs for you, but that doesn't mean you shouldn't be investigating other programs.
I think you should be praying through those other programs and asking God what you should be ready. You cannot run too much of anything. So go ahead and run.
If you feel like it's helping you continue to run a program. How often can I run this program daily? Yes, you could run any of those programs daily multiple times today.
The easiest which is this person named their cancer is draining a lot and it's purged to large black red dead cells. Yes, I got that photo. Thank you.
Another purged on Thursday, same size, etc. That is I think very good news. Night time is not too restful for me.
I'm sorry, hear that. I wake up four to six times. Any suggestions to get a more personalized sleep.
You can't think about taking CBD at before you go to bed. There's another product called insomnia tall. That's by designs for health.
That has melatonin to help you fall asleep, but it also has some good herbs like malaria and the things that will help you just calm your body and help you stay sleeping also a product that could that could just help boost your adrenal glands can help you stay asleep.
There's been one of the things about waking up a night can be because your dreams are drained and you have decreased cortisol production and decreased breakdown of glycogen stores in your liver, so that's a possibility too.
And so it all depends on why you're waking up person's waking up to go to the bathroom that's whole different discussion. If the person's waking up because they have pain, that's another discussion if it's just because they're just not really calling it pain but uncomfortable because of their cancer that I would take the suggestions that I just mentioned something that would just some call me the herbs that may be help to reduce rest and CBD.
Two or three times due to the bathroom, so not an easy solution to that. For men, you think of prostate supreme.
And also, if there is any type of bladder infection.
Then it's you want to think about treating that so that can happen to two times due to cramps before going to bed once a night, I spray liquid magnesium on my legs that could be beneficial taking magnesium orally can be beneficial.
And then each time I wake up in the water before going to bed continue to lose some weight maybe a couple of pounds.
I want to work out, but sometimes I'm tired in life just doesn't allow that.
I had it.
Kachaba last week to my diet, and yesterday had it two times daily.
A little word about working out, make sure that you're just doing light workouts or light exercise. I do have a blog post on the type of exercise that person should do with cancer.
So look at that as well.
Should where should I place the crystal hammer bulb for thyroid cancer.
So if you put it up by your thyroid, you risk it the bulb just keep you awake at night, because the flashing light, I don't think I would be able to do that.
I've been placing it on my end of it for my t-shirt under the covers at night.
You could put it on your chest.
Just a little bit closer to the thyroid, especially in the winter when you may keep covers higher so you keep it covered so it doesn't keep you up.
Or next to me in bed, I think it's, I think it's better if it's on you instead of next to you.
So, but it's whatever it's most comfortable, plus it depends on whether you're sleeping on your back or your sign.
Should I be purchasing the QX tube bulb and stand for purpose of facing my head and that no, I would say no, there's not a need for that.
I'm loving the infrared sauna. That's great.
Makes me happy and boosts my mood.
Like going to a white vacation every morning, like you're sitting out here, that's fantastic.
It's really good for you. Again, the main purpose of the sauna is to help you detox through your skin and utilize that.
So that's a good, good, good thing.
Do you do genetic testing reviews for a family member? If so, do you give recommendations and attrition on what they should take?
That brings us back to this slide that are new courses.
So, what of our new courses that were operated that won't be live for probably two weeks is a course on genetics.
So, it's going to go everything genetics in that course.
And in that course, that's where people can just can purchase that course and get a genetic review done.
But if you're a family member that just call and asked to talk to Angie, she can get your all set up for that.
So, we used to not new genetic reviews for people that are not family members of patients.
Now that we're going to have this course going, that enables us to do genetic reviews on any one.
So, because people will be watching the videos and learning from that, not doing is getting one of the ones calls and have a genetic review by monthly Zoom call where they can ask questions that will be within.
So, the answer is yes, failure risk and new genetic reviews, and yes, they will get recommendations for nutrition and diet.
So, contact the clinic and ask for Angie to get that set up and we can get a genetic kit sent out for your family.
I have bold on bold on the left hip, which seems to be getting more restrictive and paid with time.
Be considered a hip replacement surgery, my ecologist suggests that no surgeon will touch me, given the colorectal cancer.
I'm not talked to any surgeons for that reason, but I'm thinking it might anyhow.
Cutter's clinic protocol seems to be proceeding slowly, but fine.
Also, I am not doing any alopathic standards of care, and hopefully will not be too.
So, it may be a while or my goal of dissolving the tumor is reached, not sure the hip situation and weight, but also concerned with what might be going, might be wrong.
I tried supplements to rebuild the cartilage, thoughts on suggestions on the situation.
So, yeah, but you have bold on bold on a in a joint that is certainly a major issue and you're right.
Your ecologist is probably speaking from experience and saying that the surgeons are not going to want to deal with somebody who has active cancer.
Because they don't know what is going on with possible metastasis to the area, they're not going to do a hip replacement surgery for those kind of risks.
There may be bold loss, there may be, you know, comorbidities to the cancer itself that could put you at greater risk.
You have the possibility that somebody asked this question about using roll on therapy, which is injection.
I think it's like a saline type solution into a joint.
I believe it's really only done in the, the D and the hip.
Maybe a practitioner that does that, maybe you already investigated that and they won't touch you either, but that seems like it's not going to be a contract indicative injection for cancer patients.
I think it would have anything to do with making anybody's cancer worse even if there was cancer in there.
I would look at that.
Yeah, it's, it's a difficult, it's a difficult thing that if you're taking different, if you taking supplements, the first supplement you think of is copyright and if you've done that kind of stuff, if you're bold on bold, it's not going to help that much.
Yeah, I didn't wish I had a better answer for you.
You know, there's cancer patients that have metastasis to the bold and they have bold loss and a fracture in the bold and they still do surgery on that to put it a rod or something like that, so.
I would think you would be able to find a surgery that would still go ahead and surgery.
I would investigate that if I were you, at least talk to somebody if you have confidence in them, maybe you want to be bold.
Well, you will a person get the same benefit using decaf coffee with coffee animals.
The answer is yes and no, so some people have a sensitivity to caffeine and they just cannot do caffeine coffee animals.
They absorb it real quickly and they just get wired and then they can't sleep.
What are the solutions if that is the case is to do your coffee animals in the morning, not at night.
Secondly, if you're absorbed the fluid of the coffee animal too fast, it isn't a possible side that you dehydrate it.
So you're absorbed in your larger test of fluid, including the caffeine and that is part of the issue, so you might want to investigate that.
Other people just have a sensitivity to caffeine in general can't drink caffeine at all, and it does have to do with a specific gene.
That you don't detoxify caffeine well at all, so they can't drink caffeine, they copy your caffeinated beverages, they just don't do well with those and I understand that.
Those people we have suggested to do chamomile animals, chamomile tea just making chamomile tea and do that.
You can do decapitated coffee animals, even decapitated coffee still has some caffeine in it to make sure you use a water decapitated coffee, not a chemical decapitated coffee.
However, when you don't have caffeine in whatever you're using for an animal, whether you're doing an animal with a tea or a lower caffeinated product with the decap coffee, you're not going to get as great a stimulation of the parasympathetic.
So that's really the whole purpose of the coffee animal.
So yes, it does make a difference when you're using something without caffeine or something decapitated with lower caffeine.
The whole idea with the coffee animal coffee that we use, the gold rose coffee, is that it's a higher level of caffeine because the higher level of caffeine stimulates the parasympathetics more effectively.
So it's really the caffeine that's stimulating the parasympathetic nervous system. So yeah, you are losing some of that benefits.
So do investigate.
You know, the reason why you don't want to use the caffeine is it because you're dehydrated or is it just because of the sensitivity to to coffee to to caffeine in general.
Oh, chat question. We have a P.E.M.A. pad that fits onto a chair.
Can I use right while sitting on the pad when they cancel each other out? No, you can use the right while you're doing the P.E.M.A. completely different frequencies.
You're fine. You could do the P.E.M.A. and the right at the same time. Any other questions?
Why can't I spray your bug spray on skin?
You can use your bug spray, the bug spray on your skin. You just have to be careful. It isn't essential oil. Just have to be careful. It's irritating. I use the bug spray on my skin. I put it on my grandkids skin.
We use it on the dog. So, even the little grandkids, the only thing with that caveat is that if you're really super sensitive to different essential oils, you just have to be careful of that.
That's the whole thing.
I like the paleo pops. Thanks. Are they good? Kind of addictive.
If I am by the case for the office, I'd like to go and spur it's fine if they disappear very fast.
Please repeat what minerals to tank if having crayons.
So, I use the multi-min plus. So, that's our brand, the cutters put it multi-min plus. It's called clear multi-min plus as it has a greater variety of minerals in there.
And I'll take anywhere between two and six a day to get it done. You know, if how I feel or if I own a lot during the day, sweaty the whole day on a Friday or Saturday or something.
And so I'll take my take six and full spread about through the day as I come in. I'll grab a couple.
Always with minerals and pretty sure I made a video on a blog post about this really important with minerals as you take the minerals.
The way they are key-lated. So a mineral has to be key-lated. You want to be taking minerals the way they're key-lated in nature by God or us to consume.
You're made to consume the vegetables that have minerals in it. So where do you get your minerals, you get your minerals through your vegetables.
So it hurts me. It hurts my brain when I hear things like this on social media.
You should use cast-ired pants because that's a great way to get extra iron.
No, that isn't a great way to get extra iron. We were not created to be able to digest and absorb elemental iron like that.
So that is not a good form of iron. So you want iron from a plant source.
But minerals from a plant source. Well, how am I supposed to get a plant source? I mean, I can't get all what I need from a plant source.
Well, then you get it the way it would be in a plant. So a plant takes minerals from the soil takes like let's use calcium takes calcium carbonate, which is limestone in the soil.
And it converts it to a different form of calcium that is easily absorbed and digested and absorbed by a correct order by humans.
And it's key-lated in a way with a double bond to an amino acid.
So any good sample of a good reputable supplement company that sells minerals or a multiple complex is going to have the minerals in that form with a double bond to an amino acid.
So there are iron that we sell all forms of the iron that we sell I think we have three different types of iron is iron that is double bonded to glycine, I think, which is an amino acid, all the minerals that we sell are double bonded most of the glycine, double bonded to an amino acid.
So a company that makes for the powdered minerals that can sell it to some of the companies, there's two companies, I think they're actually sister companies, what is called tracks and what is called Albion.
And they make those minerals that sell it, they don't sell directly, they sell it to some of the companies. So I always want to get minerals that are double bonded to an amino acid.
It's one of the ways that you can tell if you're going to crappy supplement isn't fit sale sell says calcium carbonate, although there will be some calcium, a little bit of calcium carbonate in that that's naturally occurring in some things, but when that's the form of calcium is calcium carbonate or magnesium carbonate.
It's literally just washed limestone that's you're just eating dirt that's not how we're supposed to get our minerals we're not supposed to eat dirt plants eat dirt converted to the form that that we eat plants.
So that's why you should eat animals that eat plants and and eat organic plants if at all possible. So and this is why you know grass fed beef is even better the grade fed beef because you're getting the, you're getting Omega's from that as well.
Just understanding minerals and understanding food. I have finished my first round of vibrance and come down with the modia finishing antibiotics tonight and developed a fever today. Oh, she I'm sorry about that.
And that is the problem. I mean, the negative thing about chemo therapy.
You know, the positive thing is it can kill your your cancer, but the negative is that it can kill your immune system.
And that's why if you're going to do chemotherapy, it's so important that you know you do as much right feet as possible and that you may even have to.
So everybody reacts differently to chemo therapy. Some people sail through it pretty well. Some people it just beats the immune system to daylight.
Partly it has to do with your static detoxification pathway. Typically your, your side of chrome piece 54 and your on one pathways that detoxify these chemos, you have defects of those pathways, you don't detoxify a very fast.
And then it just stays in your system and beats the daylights out of you. And it's beating the daylights out of the more highly metabolic cell lines and that is your immune system.
And then you end up with secondary infections like this and that's not good.
So you may be one of those people that need to bump up your immune stimulants.
Even more when you're doing the chemo, which what are the immune stimulants are typically what we're having one for the cancer typically it's going to be.
I don't have your file in front of you. You're taking a severe stimulus, but it could be the view to could be a mushroom complex, it could be even taking more green story that time will help because that's going to give you.
Better of you boosting just by that doing that alone. So any other questions. No.
Well, this is a short zoom call today. All right.
If you jumped out here late, we got a lot of new courses coming out please don't buy any of the courses for yourselves.
All our patients we're going to give access to the courses as soon as we can figure out how to do that. So hang with us.
Is wheat grass powder good.
Yeah, you could have some wheat grass powder.
I wouldn't just do just solely wheat grass powder. I would do greens mix. That's why I like a bunch of greens for so much is because it's such a variety of stuff up there.
So you get a real good balance.
So I would suggest you're if you're not already doing the greens first that you do greens first instead of wheat grass.
Now understand a lot of wheat grass powder may have gluten too. It depends on when the wheat grass was cut.
I think it's about 10 to 12 days, the regress then it has contains gluten.
If it's less than 10 days, then it doesn't contain gluten. So gluten is an issue. You've got to keep that in your mind as well.
Is juicing my vegetables okay instead of Stevie. Yes, but do remember that juicing your vegetables. It's still raw.
This person has this question is fairly young. So you should probably should have much problem with that. But as we age, it's more difficult to break that down.
Even though you're pre-digested with juicing, it can still be hard on your gut.
So if you have any gut problems with juicing, then just back off.
But it also depends on how much you juicing, going to say, well, juicing, you know, 12 to 20 ounces a day should be just fine.
Of course, even that can be difficult if you're 80 years old. But just watch your gut is the answer.
Make sure you're not getting telly eggs. What would you see for anything like that.
All right. Well, I will say goodbye to everybody then today.
And remember, future times, I try to get these videos up the same night, if at all possible.
So there's a time that you ask questions, a day you ask questions, you can't be on the Zoom call. I try to get them off the same night.
All right. Be blessed. I'll be praying for everybody. Bye bye.